remember when I got my first job as a graphic designer
when I walked into the office
it was uh
I was in the art department for um
a corporate hotel
and it was a privately held corporate hotel
so I was like
literally would ride the elevator up to the corporate level
um I don't know if you've ever heard of Westgate Resorts
but um
David Siegel like
when you got out of the elevator
David Siegel's office doors were right there
and then I walked around the corner
so I was like
literally on the executive floor at this like
bajillion dollar
there's like documentaries about him
it was it was fucking so overwhelmingly intimidating
I was like oh
my god I feel like I don't belong here
like the imposter syndrome was so fucking strong
then when I walked into the office that I had to work
they were like oh
here you go and there was like eight
there was one
two three four
there was like six graphic designers
our creative director had his office inside of our office
there was like this like
little glass fish bowl of his office inside of the creative department
it was so overwhelming
and then all the cubicles were open
and the way you sat your computer was kind of in the corner
and so anybody who walked up and down could see what you were working on
so I was fucking mortified
I was like I have to design
I don't know I feel like it's
it is such a private like
I'm always so impressed at musicians or anybody who puts their art out there
because you aren't putting a part of like
your heart out there for people
and you're like
oh my god
are they gonna like it
like oh
like what if they say something uglier
oh my god
what if it's not received well anyway
I met one of my like
best friends in life there
we still are friends to this day
her ex husband is actually being a total piece of shit right now
and treating her like shit
and there are just so many women in my life that have um
supported me and encouraged me
and honestly
there are so many men in my life that have hurt me and disappointed me
and let me down
so
um thank you for the support
sorry to get all emotional
but I've poured my heart and soul into everything so thank you